Julie how do you guys fact-check a story
very good question we've had questions
about sources we've had questions about
fake news etc we've had a couple
different things that we do here number
one we don't do stories with very rare
exceptions based on one source okay if
that one source is let's not name names
right now we've talked about it before
that's not what this is about
depending on what the one source is we
might do a story we might not write if
it's the New York Times versus if it's
insert here internet source here we
might do a story based on the New York
Times reporting because saying as
reported by the New York Times is very
different than saying as reported by
bogus fake news site number 347 dot-com
so that that's that there is a
difference there but generally we try to
do stories with multiple sources and
also we will always follow back the
articles to the original source and this
is something that with all these
websites now that rewrite news and
repackage news you get a it's sort of
like the game telephone where every
layer gets slightly further from the
actual original story sources so we try
pad to always go back to the original
reporting source if it's a website that
is doing summaries of news will click
back or just have to search for what are
the original sources here and very often
the story we end up doing based on the
original sources is different than the
story we would have done based on the
rewriter headline and I think it's
pretty obvious to what we're relating to
the audience as facts that we know from
the original source articles yes and
what we're adding to it as our
perspective our speculation no yet on
our own history our own historical
knowledge all that stuff and the other
thing is that even for so you might have
a story you let's say you have a New
York Times story and it presents let's
say there are 15 relevant facts to the
news story seven of them might be fact
specific to what just happened that are
directly sourced the other eight might
be facts stated by the New York Times
article or whatever that are not
directly related to the breaking news
that you can fact check so for example
think about a story about some space
Expo
in news right there maybe 15 facts some
of those might be this scientist who is
working on this project just said X
original source great that's what the
scientist said but usually it would be
filled in with other facts like for
example this is the first planet of this
type that has been discovered we can
independently fact check that right
there are an abundance of sources that
would talk about the list of planets of
X type that have been found and you can
still independently fact check a lot of
what's in a breaking news story right
and you know if a source has a political
leaning one way or another so if they're
just telling you what a person said in a
quote attributed to them yeah generally
speaking you can just take that to be
true right you don't have to corroborate
that yourself but if they're making it
an indication on the consequences of one
policy proposal based on Congressional
Budget Office numbers from ten years ago
maybe that's the sort of thing you
should look into because they can kind
of you know there's a lot of talk about
alternative facts now but there's
alternative arguments and you can you
can your support and argument one way or
another depending on what facts you view
and part of what you're talking about is
also distinguishing between news
reporting and opinion journals and I've
said this before and I'll say it again
sometimes people will write to me they
say David I love your show because
you're less bias than Fox News's reports
okay you know compliments are great but
this is an opinion show and we are
basing our opinion on independently
reported facts that we are not reporting
we are sourcing and to compare our level
of quote bias to what you would
experience during a fox news news report
we're not even talking about the same
types of news and that's another
important thing you're sort of getting
at which is distinguishing between types
of news and opinion journalists and Fox
News does not even honest and how they
brand themselves if they came out and
said that yeah we are the media for the
Republican Party we'd at least be able
to respect that but instead they have
this tagline of fair and balanced where
everyone knows that's not true
absolutely bogus yeah so those are some
of the ideas that that I have Julie in
terms of how to fact-check a story